so look another reminder this  generational wealth webinar is coming up  a lot of insight we got on the  Rockefeller family Medici family Ford  family Vander there's a lot of some of  them that did it right some of them that  didn't do it right if you haven't yet  registered get registered you're going  to want to learn from their mistakes and  you're going to want to learn from the  things they did right specifically how  to not raise spoiled kids for them to  earn how to get the money anyways  obviously I'm thinking about it for  myself as well and I want to share the  Insight with you so if you haven't  registered yet click on the link above  or below I'll see you there